in the early days of photography all you
had were shades of gray every color on
the spectrum from red to violet was
squashed down by the photographic
process and actually early photographic
film didn't even manage that it used
chemicals that were mostly sensitive to
blue light so if something was bright
red the chemicals would barely react to
it it just looked black on camera which
is why dark rooms where the
photosensitive film was developed could
be lit with red light without ruining
the pictures it turned out that film
like that would also react to x-rays now
visible light can pass through some
solid objects as anyone who's ever held
the hand up to a light and looked their
veins can tell you but x-rays with a
higher energy and shorter wavelength
pass through objects a lot more easily
so the picture doesn't get scattered
into a blurry mess so an x-ray photo
takes those short wavelengths and
translates them into something that our
eyes can see
unfortunately that higher energy also
means that x-rays are ionizing radiation
they come with a risk of cancer and
radiation poisoning before that was
known flora scopes which use your
constant beam of x-rays seemed like a
great idea now they are very carefully
controlled but x-rays aren't just one
wavelength they're also on a spectrum
from soft x-rays to hard x-rays and the
team here in Christchurch New Zealand
who are doing something that in
hindsight seems really obvious what if
you take x-rays at several different
frequencies and then translate all those
frequencies to different colors the part
of the light spectrum is the x-ray
spectrum and in the we've got a range of
energy sometimes they're called soft and
hard x-rays but the typical medical
imaging device doesn't use that
information sometimes it's used in
airport security they typically have a
couple of Detectives layers on top of
each other and they get those crude
signals out and then present it to the
eye as two different colors but we're
actually getting eight different colors
and we're doing a lot of computer
processing before we get a 3d image of
what the materials are so we actually
measure you know that's bone that's
water that's pad we started thinking
about it myself in about 2002
the designers of the detect that started
10 years before there it came out of
high-energy physics it came out of
CERN's research and trying to find the
Higgs boson equally importantly they
found a much better way of imaging
inside humans than they had before each
photon that comes in we actually measure
the energy of it
if photons come in so fast it has to do
it very very quickly the pixels are 110
micron square so their size are here's
bread and each one of them is about
three three to four thousand transistors
they're doing a lot of processing we've
only got a two dimensional image so
we've actually got to turn that into a
three dimensional image and that's
called computer tomography
we've do a lot of computer processing
and produce 3d slices any way through
the object with the resolution we've got
we've got to solve tens of billions of
equations and we've got to try and do
that very quickly the goal is to make it
as easy as possible for people to
understand from bone you'd typically use
white because that's what people think
is what bones should be but if you're
looking at something like iodine
solution of iodine is clear so we are
typically assigned red and most people
in mids and they're used to seeing
things assigned to different colors it's
a combination of what looks good what's
insure ative and what's easy to
understand we've got to the point we can
now test things in humans and we're
about to start our first clinical trial
the challenges in going from where we
were in 2006 on our first Mouse to being
able to do the first human we had to
move to the human energy range so the
x-rays you need to get through a mouse
are much softer lower energy and we need
to go to do large areas of the ticklers
so you can actually scan someone on a
reasonable time frame and then there's a
data handling issues typically we think
of scanning one liter of volume giving
us about 10 gigabytes of data can you
actually scan a large object and manage
that kind of data at the moment our
scanner uses about half as many x-rays
as a standard CT but if you think of
imaging something like a wrist which is
not radio sensitive it's not a thyroid
gland it's not a breast gland the actual
dose from the ruskin is very very low
depending on which country you live in
it's the equivalent of several hours to
a day or to a background radiation most
x-ray detectors need
to have a certain amount of photons
before you can measure them otherwise
you're in the electronic noise whereas
we work at very very low count rates and
so we can measure the statistical or the
quantum noise quite easily so we can
operate at lower doses our goal was to
keep the dose the same but provide 10
times as much information there are all
sorts of different ways of looking
inside the body
I'm really excited in the next six
months we're going to scan lots of
interesting bits like broken arms and
Galton the fingers and maybe in a year's
time start looking at more exciting
things like diseases of blocked arteries
we can actually say not just simply to
something absorbing but whether it is
calcium iodine or fat it's an injury is
there a bit of metal in there or
whatever we can answer those questions
and so we've got a great prospect of
actually seeing a lot of things that
haven't been seen before thanks to all
the team at Mars bioimaging and the
University of Canterbury pull down the
description for more about them and
about network
you